son of fuel I think that those of us I
think maybe it maybe most of us but the
thing about it is we live these lies
nothing that necessarily negative a week
we're busy so your brain doesn't have
the ability to like kind of explore
those things that we assume were those
are just dreams you know because of his
life that I have and I and I just like I
could wait a minute now I woke up in
somebody said transcending all I know
but I wasn't sleep so it's been an
actual genuine exploration who is it
then somebody really did do that I
wasn't dreaming I had just woken up and
it was life transcending all her
together so that's just me understated
it's not real not like wait a minute now
somebody said it just like I said so
that song came from that but that's what
more deep breathe but you know I started
I guess naturally I'm inclined to kind
of explore the spiritual realm so it all
got four bleep